hi everyone i'm alana and welcome to my
channel where today i am pretty stoked
to be checking out the first look
at the playstation 5 user experience or
user interface or
dashboard or whatever you want to call
it um because it feels like we've
actually not heard that much from
playstation outside of their gameplay
demos which you know
to be fair i love me some gameplay
i'm hideaki nishino hello and i head up
playstation's platform planning and a
management team which includes product
and ux design today we are finally going
to give you a look at the playstation 5.
we will see some of the features that
enable games to work together with the
hardware network to deliver a truly next
generation experience
our vision for ps5 user experience is
simple
we believe that your play time is
valuable and should be meaningful i
appreciate that
playstation team members from all around
the world work to deliver a ps5
experience
that is completely centered on you the
player
connecting you with a great play and a
passionate community
so sleek with a look and feel that's
designed for 4k tvs
the ps5 user experience was built from
the ground up to take advantage of the
console capabilities
complementing the transformative games
coming with this new generation i'm
assuming that the sound
the music is i should note that not for
this is from a pre-production
environment on the ps5 console so there
may be a few small wrinkles or minor
changes once the console launches in
november
and now let's check it out courtesy of
our own situation
it looks really pretty thanks
nishino-san
welcome to your new playstation 5
console experience
this time we've started up from rest
mode we've already created an account
and signed into playstation network
so let's log in it looks really nice is
my webcam too big
might be in this case i've resumed right
where i left off in sac boy a big
adventure
we're looking at playstation 5's control
center
from here it's one click and we're right
back into the game but let's take a
moment and look around this is very fast
the control center is always one tap of
the playstation button away
it provides immediate access to almost
everything you need from the system
without leaving the game this includes
things like seeing who is online
checking the status of a download
managing your controller power
and more note that that's terribly new
but
still appreciate it these colorful
characters
are called cards and they let you
interact with
games and the system in a variety of
ways
first as we've just resumed the control
center is showing a special card that
allows me to get up to date on
recent stories posted by publishers for
games i am following
another part here shows me recent media
i've captured from my gameplay using the
create button playstation
dual sense controller let's check out
one of the most powerful new features of
the ps5 console okay
they're actually just to the right in
this row and we call them
activities activities are part of the
plan to remove
barriers to gameplay let's get an
example of one way they're used in sac
boy a big adventure
with the tap of the playstation button
i'm back to playing the game
sacboy a big adventure is packed with
things to discover and each
level represents one type of activity i
can play many of which i can go back to
later to discover more
okay i tapped the playstation button to
bring up the control center again
i could see a number of available
activities both active and
suggested by the system let's take this
first one a big advantage
i haven't quite completed this level yet
i'm at 33
let's open it up and see more here i can
see
more information including key
objectives let's jump right into a level
and i'm seeing a very important piece of
information
here it says about 10 minutes left this
is playstation 5's personalized playtime
estimate
giving me an idea how long it will take
me okay i love that oh i'm over the top
of it
damn you webcam some activities even let
you jump directly to that place and
i like that a lot telling me how much
longer i have at a level is a great idea
because i'm a terrible person about
being like i'll just finish the level
and then it's two hours
for another example let's open that
activity back up
maybe that'll stop me from doing things
maybe i don't want to see that
i don't know it looks like i missed an
objective to
find the monk robes costume piece looks
like i need a little help
some in-game activities like this one
offer
official game help game help is included
as a benefit for active playstation plus
members in
some ps5 games in this case i can open
up that objective to get some hints
without resorting to
a web search or digging through long
videos or articles that might contain
spoilers
i never trust this stuff this
particularly just right here for a
second
and i completely so i never trust this
stuff a because
i know people who've worked on teams
that have had to make this stuff
sometimes it's outsourced
and b i know people who've been on the
other side
where they've worked at companies where
someone was like hey you have to make
help videos
and they don't have video editors or
anyone who's been assigned to make those
things
um tips and games when it
basically it usually means there is no
one to actually efficiently make it
um unless they are hiring staff at every
single studio to make this
they have to be outsourcing i know that
was the thing that machinima did
um or pulling it from the internet
themselves
and i think for the most part it's
always bad
obviously any generation maybe they
could be the ones to nail it maybe
playstation could do a great job of this
but um
generally uh i always flag that in my
head as
every experience that i i have had or
that i know other people who i have like
friends who work at uh publishers or
developers have had with this kind of
thing
is always a disaster for someone
so i don't know whatever it's a cool
feature in theory but i don't trust that
it'll be consistent
without leaving the game sometimes it's
really useful to be able to see the hint
on screen
while you play some cards can be put in
a picture in picture mode
or as shown here a side by side view
super cool and if you pin a card you can
access it via the control center at any
time
now let's go find those rascally monk
robes
how'd you miss those dummy game help
[Music]
the team at playstation wanted to make
it really easy to chat with your friends
on the playstation 5 console
so let's check out how it works
interactive notification with the tap of
the playstation button
and i've decided to join the voice chat
that my friend just entered
now my friend could have done this on
the playstation app for mobile devices
from a ps4
or in this case from a ps5 the dual
sense controller features an integrated
microphone too so i could start talking
right away
but i always have the ability to hit the
mute button on the controller or in the
menus
parties take on an expanded role with
ps5
and they now provide persistent spaces
to connect with groups that you play
with
here i have a couple of friends chatting
away in the party
one of them has started sharing their
screen so you guys don't see it cut off
like that
there you go
looks like they're playing uncharted the
lost legacy we can chat while we play
and i can watch his progress as well
while you play
i love that i use discord for that all
the time
[Music]
this is another card that can be put in
picture-in-picture mode or pinned to the
cell
that is how you play it awesome you can
access it anytime via the control center
too but let's dismiss it for now
that rules i love that okay let's review
so far we've seen how activities on ps5
will make it easier and
faster to hop back into ps5 games and
how you can get in-game help and chat
with your friends
so that leaves online multiplayer gaming
let's check it out
i see that some of my friends are online
so it's time to say goodbye to sacboy
for now
and spin up a match of destruction
all-stars
one of my friends in the party has
already started a match and we can join
them from this card in control center
also pretty cool
and there we go destruction all stars
now quickly starts thanks to ps5's ultra
high speed
ssd
okay i think we've got enough people on
our party so let's jump in
we're keeping the focus on ps5's user
experience today so
let's zip ahead so we can see more
and just like that we're in we don't
have time to play a full match today
but i do think we have time to take a
quick photo to do that
i'll just tap the create button on the
dual sense controller
ps5 is always capturing recent gameplay
but when you compare a shot even using
in-game photo mode
you can capture a high quality
screenshot here this optimizes capturing
the moment
letting you review and choose to share
later on i should mention
screenshots and video can be captured at
up to 4k on the ps5 console
cool okay so far we've shown off
how to jump into activities how to chat
with your friends
get into groups together to play
capturing game play
all of that while in game but what if i
want to play a different game
a great question what if
welcome to the playstation 5 home screen
i really like this
where you'll land when you start up from
a powered off state and where you'll go
when you want to choose a new game to
play or download the layout of the space
is designed to present games and game
content beautifully on a 4k display
with simple and super fast access to
what you need
and in case you're wondering media
related apps will have their own space
like this one but today we're focused on
gaming
each game has its own hub completely
integrated so all you need to do is
scroll down to see activities you can
jump
right into video clips stories about the
game
dlc and more i wonder how much people
will actually
four titles will benefit from some of
these features too
let's move one spot to the left and
check out explore
which brings together all your games we
saw a view of this from the control
center earlier
and another view will also be in the new
playstation app for mobile devices
explore keeps you in the loop with
official stories from playstation and
from all the games you're following
including
trending media unsure how much i'll use
this testing and learning about this
feature in the u.s at launch curious
though so not everyone will have this on
day one
but it gives you a good idea of the
direction
and this is playstation store for people
very excited about this game it's
completely integrated into the
system it's not a standalone app anymore
browsing for new games to play will be
easier thanks to the speed of ps5
and a more personalized store experience
and here you'll be able to browse the
latest games and deals you'll find ps5
games and many backward compatible ps4
games too
i'm sad to say but we are almost out of
time so let's pull up control center one
more time with the tap of the
playstation button
why don't we quickly share that photo we
took in destruction all-stars
we can find recently captured media in
this handy card in control center
from here we can do some quick edits but
i think i'm ready to share it right now
on playstation 5 i have the option to
share videos and images to supported
external services
or i can send them directly to one of my
parties remember
parties are bigger than just voice chat
now so i'll select one of my favorite
potty stuff is is very neat like a cool
evolution
message here the dual sensor controller
makes this really easy
not an evolution of discord exposed but
i attempt to be more like this
languages so you no longer have i'm
going to use type messages with the
keyboard if you don't want to
simply select the microphone button
here's a cool detail
if my friend hasn't yet played the
activity where i captured this media
and the game's developer thinks that
activity spoilers
they'll receive a warning before well
that's it for our demo
there are many more exciting features we
couldn't get to today but we're super
excited to share
more of the playstation 5 and
playstation app user experience with you
in the coming weeks headed to launch and
of course this is just a first look at
what fans can expect on day one the team
at playstation is committed to evolving
this experience
with our community in the months ahead
we look forward to sharing more
thanks for watching thank you bud
um so i think it looks really
nice like i think that ui is very pretty
it looks really clean
i like it a lot there are definitely
some features there that i'm not sure if
i'll use
like jumping into a certain level um
being in in the cards like i wonder how
how much you can customize that to stop
it from being cluttered
um and the news story stuff i generally
am not going to use my console as a
source for news i'm going to get that
elsewhere
uh however i don't have any complaints
about features i won't necessarily use
like if i don't necessarily use it
i don't you know that's not a problem um
as long as i can organize it the way
that i want to
um you know if other people want to use
it that's great i have no complaints
about there being features that i don't
care about you know um i definitely
think the
party evolutions are really cool i like
the idea i think
of being told or being able to
immediately jump into
to um something that i was already
making progress on and being told how
much time there is remaining
if it's personalized i think that could
be really interesting so
yeah overall i think it looks really
sleek it looks really pretty
it seemed very fast which you love to
see
super into that potty system that is a
thing that i actually think i will use
quite a bit since
frankly a lot of my socializing
especially in 2020
is on consoles um or on discord where
lots of my friends are playing video
games at once that's that's pretty
awesome so
general impressions i think it's really
nice uh
yep that's pretty much it happy with it
uh alrighty you guys i'm alana i will
see you guys next time
you